the indians will counter tonight with
right-hander aaron savali he comes in
with a 3-5 record but a solid 3.80
earned run average
well that's bases loaded now for edwin
encarnacion the former indian
now the 01 and he breaks his bat hits a
slow roller to short lindor will set
throw to first and then carnacion leaves
them loaded it was a 26-pitch inning for
aaron savali but he gets out of it
without any run scoring and the indians
are coming to bat sox will be looking
for dane dunning to deliver an efficient
starting performance tonight dunning 2-0
and five major league starts with an
impressive 2.33 earned run average and
now jose ramirez
now the 3-1 is swung on sock deep to
right field it is gone
jose ramirez makes it three-nothing
indians jose with home run number 16 is
ninth from the left side of the plate
rbi's number 39 40 and 41
and the indians jump on top three to
nothing
so at three nothing indians tying run
now at home plate in the person of tim
anderson savali's pitch
swung on smashed up the middle knocked
down by savali picks it goes to third
one ramirez throw to first double play
anderson didn't run out of the box and
cesar hernandez the batter
singleton scored in the first
line drive base hit right field coming
around third naylor will be waved home
mazzara's throw to the plate and it is
in time but
grand dog couldn't come up with it
naylor scores four-nothing indians that
was a heck of a throw by bisara and if
grandall hangs on they're out of the
inning
and here is ramirez who hit the
three-run homer standing at the plate
now at second and third and two outs
2-2 on the ground right side will be
fielded there by anderson on the other
side of the second base he'll throw to
first in time
and the inning has come to an end but
not before the indian strike for one
more run
now with a man at second it's nomar
mazzara to the plate
here's the 0-1 off speed swung on line
to first caught by santana on the
backhand
nice play by carlos santana
retires mazzara and the white sox in the
top half of the fourth inning we head to
the bottom of the inning it's the tribe
for chicago nothing so second and third
now though for jose abreu
three and one
jose smokes it to center field
tim scores here comes yasmani it's a 4-2
ball game and the rbi king
continues to pound away
55 runs batted in now for jose abreu and
now to lloyd jimenez has the tying run
to the plate with two down in the inning
and loy on 1-0 fly ball right center
field to the track it's gone
bring him home and a tie with him
home run number 14 out of the year for
eloy jimenez 41 runs batted in
and most importantly this game is tied
here in the fifth inning
carlos santana will step to the plate
in the air deep left field jimenez
looking up it is gone to souvenir city
for carlos santana and oh baby is that
just what the doctor ordered
he puts the indians right back on top
and santana gets his sixth home run of
the season
it's his second against white sox
pitching on the year that'll bring up
nick madrigal here so the tying run will
come to the plate
the pitch madrigal drives one to deep
right on the run of snake when he's
racing back reaching up and makes a
staggering catch as he gets to the track
naquin was shallow and right and oh he
almost got burned but great recovery by
naquin
what a time this would be for front meal
to break out of it
ron mio reyes
tonight has struck out twice and
grounded out
bases loaded one out two two
in the air
right center field it's deep roberts
back on the track at the wall makes the
catch
tagging and coming home to score is
cesar hernandez moving to third on the
play jose ramirez it's a 7-4 indians
lead as reyes gets his 29th rbi on the
year well good job well done
and runners now at the corners with two
men out and tyler naked when the batter
tonight he is oh for three and now
hitless in his last 13 advance
oh and to the count
and that one's served into left center
field coming in now yellow jimenez he
slides and hold on he did
he makes the catch in left field and the
inning has come to an end
now with two away runner at third base
to the top of the order now for lindor
one ball two strike pitch and that's on
the ground to the right side
it'll be fielded by madrigal he'll throw
out lindor and the inning has come to an
end we head to the ninth inning white
sox need three to tie it four to take
the lead
now to the top of the order for tim
anderson
the pitch and he socks it high in the
air to deep center back is to shields on
the warning track at the wall he jumps
in he made the catch
scampering back to first is madrigal
on a tremendous leaping catch at the
wall in center by delano de shields
so james mccann getting a chance here
first at bat
he is the time run at home plate with
one out seven to four indians sox first
and second one out in the ninth the
one-two offering
straight three called on a backdoor
slider james mccann backing away now
barking at dan bellino
as that is out number two
and dan bellino has done that all night
long to hitters on both sides rick
renteria just got thrown out of the game
tom boschenek says that the
mild-mannered white sox have suffered
their first ejection of the year
so now two outs two on and the tying run
is abreu at home plate here it comes
and a slider straight three call the
back doordoom ball game
and the indians reduce their magic
number to one
and if seattle falls to houston tonight
the indians are in the playoffs for the
fourth time in five years